hello folks and welcome back to the show
that today features international travel
fabulously lavish clothing and lots of
martinis
no the brass here rotten tomatoes is not
whisking me away on a vacation
no matter how well deserved one might be
yeah you're right i don't work that hard
it is spy versus spy versus another spy
using your own powers of sleuthing and
deductive reasoning you've probably
already figured out that james bond is
gonna show up today
and he's gonna have his very
well-manicured hands full as he tangles
with fellow hall of fame
secret agents ethan hunt and jason
bourne
hopefully someone reminded mr bourne his
memory can be a little spotty
in one corner it's the granddaddy of
them all the legendary double 07 whose
reputation for foiling villains
is matched only by his bedroom prowess
which in turn
is only matched by his liver's endurance
in another corner is ethan hunt the
daring american
who seems to thrive when the pressure is
the greatest and the heights are the
highest
and in the third corner it's a triangle
today kids it's
jason bourne who excels at close quarter
combat and avoiding
all cameras not hinged to a shake weight
to be the best spy today these fellas
will have to prove not only how mighty
their respective film franchises are
but whether any of us would actually
trust them with a real world mission
impossible you say well i say here is
how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score
round three spy hard round four iconic
moments
and then we'll do a wild card round that
unfortunately will not
involve johnny english come on he's
funny
and while half the population is
spawning over how hot r3 sexy spies are
jay english and nielsen leslie nielsen
could be getting a real spy job done you
know what the winner today takes on the
winner of nielsen in england
okay i feel better now come ye tinkers
rescue taylor city soldiers
the time is nigh to determine the
greatest cinematic spy
of them all let's get it on
jesus christ that's bond james bond
what are you talking about round one box
office for all the credit spies get is
undetectable masters of secrecy
they sure have left a big footprint at
the movie theaters
any one of these three fellas would be
instantly disavowed
as soon as their own government saw them
on one of the movie posters that they
make
but wow do they attract fans james bond
jason bourne and ethan hunt have been
the linchpins to three of the most
successful
action movie franchises ever but who
comes out on top
that was not a euphemism mr bond stop
chuckling
just relax i'm sorry but while you are
kicking back you can also rest on your
walls as the all-time box office king
when it comes to super spies as one
might expect the total gross for all the
bond movies
far exceeds that of the mission
impossible and born franchises
simply because jimmy has been solving
problems
since the early 1960s back then mission
impossible was just a tv show
and jason bourne wasn't even a confused
twinkle in his daddy's eye
all told bond films have notched a
worldwide total
of 16.75 billion dollars when we adjust
for inflation
including 5 billion bucks for sean
connery's movies alone
daniel craig comes in at second place
with 3.75 billion dollars he actually
has a chance to pass the original bond
if no time to die
is more like skyfall and less like
quantum of solace
and although mission impossible is only
done 4.89 billion dollars and bourne is
just total 2.19 billion bucks
here's where it gets interesting the box
office average per movie
makes this round very competitive per
flick the bourne movies average and
impressive
438 million dollars worldwide and
shockingly
it's the bourne legacy with a slightly
higher total than the average of the
matt damon
born movies which total four james bond
topples jason and his knock off easily
sporting a healthy 644 million dollar
per
movie average headlined by daniel
craig's 893 million dollar
average but it's mission impossible that
far outweighs the averages of bond and
born
any way you slice it across the earth
tom cruise's ethan hunt
averages 815 million dollars per outing
and here in the states
they rake in 275 million per so whereas
james bond's movie total certainly helps
pad
his bank account and may help him win
later rounds here
it's all about what can we bank on each
and every time
out of the gate and while craig and sean
connery have competitive average totals
with the one true ethan hunt
folks like timothy dalton pierce brosnan
and even roger moore fall well short of
mission impossible numbers
the lesson here hitting for power is
great but hitting for average
makes you a winner ethan hunt is
currently doing both very well
look matt damon is a certifiable a-list
star and the james bond mythology alone
is enough to get plenty of butts in
seats
but tom cruise may be the most bankable
movie star in the history of the sport
and for that ethan hunt steals round one
now go celebrate by doing some
ridiculous stunt that drives insurance
people bonkers
what the hell is he doing find it best
not to look round two
tomato meter slash audience score the
tomato meter and audience core can be
very diverse metrics when it comes to
cinematic quality but one thing the
critics and movie going public can agree
on
is these three spy franchises are
unequivocally fresh
mission impossible born and bond all
have fresh averages for the movies
on both the tomato meter and audience
score bourne is the leader as far as the
audience is concerned
with a 77 percent average followed by
mission impossible 72 percent
and bonds 63 percent meanwhile
on the tomato meter side of things the
top two crisscross
and mission impossible jumps to the lead
with 79 percent
ahead of born at 73 percent and bond
within
on brand 69
but just like the box office round those
initial numbers don't quite tell the
whole story
first of all mission impossible in
bourne have 11 movies between them
and bond has 27 films all on his own
yes i tossed in the david niven casino
royale put some respect on his name
mr niven's turn as bond won't help 07
get a win here
but george lazenby might on her
majesty's secret service was george's
loan outing his bond
but it serves to put him at 81 percent
on the tomato meter
trailing only sean connery's 83 percent
average
matt damon's born slate comes in third
across all three franchises with an 80.5
percent average
and mission impossible was fourth with
the 79 percent
the bottom line is this round is as
competitive as it comes
numbers wise for shits and giggles i'm
tossing austin powers into the shag fest
and he comes out with a barely randy 59
tomato meter average see mike now you
gotta make one more to get that
franchise fresh
yeah baby
despite jaws maybe falling in love sort
of at the end of moonraker
roger moore's bond set can't quite
average fresh but it's an
oh so close 57 percent however brosnan
dalton and craig
are all residents of freshville and if
we're looking at the numbers to tell us
the story
the clearest gap between these
franchises isn't on the tomato meter or
the audience score
it's in the film totals again 27 movies
the fact that bond is such a catherine
heigl fan that he made one movie for
every one of her bridesmaid dresses
is nuts how original what will they
think of next
and it also shows that as impressive as
the legacy of a 20 year old franchise
like bourne or a mid-20s age series like
mission impossible is
james bond has been thrilling us
romancing ladies and knocking back adult
beverages
for almost 60 years and yet his stux
still fits better than ever
round two goes to bond gold bond and
double 07 powders his way to a tie at
the top with ethan hunt
you know that's not half bad i'm gonna
have to think up a name for that
jason bourne now would be a good time to
remember that
you're pretty good this spy stuff too
hey jason
are you with me god the guy treadstone
that ring a bell
he's worse than the winter soldier who
am i
round three spy hard okay see there's a
reason why i tried to cushion the blow
at the top of the show
leslie nielsen once again not going to
be making an appearance in this round
as fun as spy hard may have been
nielsen's most famous character of all
time lieutenant frank drebin
would not have made a very good spy
which raises the question
do any of our three competitors today
make a truly great
spy all of our gentlemen callers have
qualities that help them get the job
done
and in the case of both ethan hunt and
james bond their wins are more often
than not victories for the team
hunt always has a ragtag cast of
able-bodied support staff
aiding him in his very tough to
accomplish missions ranging from the
tech nerds to understudies to his equals
in the form of a female whether it's
ving rhames's luther
rebecca ferguson's faust simon pegg's
character jeremy renner or paula patton
ethan has had plenty of good role
players over the years but it always
seems like
he's most willing to do the heavy
lifting which in his case usually
translates into
strapping himself to the side of a
moving plane
or dangling from a cliff listening to
metallica or successfully leaping
between buildings
apologies almost successfully leaping
between buildings
ugh did your whole theater cringe when
they actually ran that in the movie
[Music]
hunt also has good instincts when a
particular agency is up to no good or
someone in his own inner circle
might be double-crossing him this
intuition was no doubt developed because
um
like a lot of people in his life have
been no good double crossers
i'm just glad emilio estevez's jack
isn't alive to be disappointed by his
fellow agents
instincts are similarly one of the best
assets for jason bourne
and while he's an expert at sniffing out
when his own country is selling him a
bag of fake magic beans
just to get him back under their wing
his intuition is best utilized when it's
for the sake
of his own survival you'll never find
born trusting that day's newspaper much
less a cia operative
or a fellow rogue spy it took the dude
up until like his fourth movie to trust
julius styles and she was in 10 things i
hate about you and that movie's great
it came out in 1999 three years before
the bourne identity in 2002 so i'm
willing to bet jason bourne never saw
that flick
david webb might have that look that one
up
it's funny but if born relies on his
instincts to help him survive
the payoff to continue escaping death
has got to be his fighting ability
for all the suave of a bond or the
daring of a hunt
i will take jason bourne if this all
just came down to a street fight
jason bourne recruits martial arts
techniques as diverse as filipino cowley
israeli krav maga bruce lee's wing chun
and
jeet kune do or if you prefer look at
this
he'll just knock out with a single punch
jake paul
you're next
[Applause]
born's nose for survival was equaled by
bonds thirst for a good time
or so it would appear james bond is
surely a hooted parties but he's only
attending those as a cover
so he can get his mission accomplished
defeat the bad guys and oh boy he's
leaving with someone else's wife
whoo boy okay so look maybe james is
guilty of getting a tad more sidetracked
than born
or hunt but to be fair hunt is now
kind of sort of spoken is michelle
monahan still around i know he cared
about her at one time and in bourne's
first outing he hooked up
with francophotante so even the most
hardcore super spy
has an eye that can occasionally wander
but with his other well-trained eye bond
fixates on all the cool gadgets his
buddy
q drums up for him need an exploding pen
for this task
gotcha how about a tiny emergency
defibrillator
no problem jetpack hey we're not going
to pay for it
here it is bond has technological
advances to spare
now would he trust those gloves outside
of the dubai skyscraper like ethan hunt
did
i'm not sure and when it's red dead but
double 07's aston martin can sure zoom
away from an incoming sandstorm the
thing that sways me towards jason bourne
is his refusal to ever give up his
positioning his location
even his heart the key to any good spy
is not getting caught
and whereas bond and hunt are in the
open even when they can no longer fully
rely on the very agency that sent them
there in the first place
born is fueled by his constant paranoia
that no one is as they seem and
everyone must be kept at an arm's length
even when he does come out of his shell
and arrange to meet someone it's going
to be a series of expertly timed bus
stops
ringing pay phones that they still have
them security camera blind spots
just to give the guy a fist bump is
jason born by far the loneliest of our
three heroes today
without hesitation yes but this round
isn't called commitment issues
it's called spy heart and no one spies
harder or better
than david jason bourne this round is
his
and we enter round four with a three-way
tie at the top
get some rest pam you look tired
four iconic moments yes it's a trifecta
deadlock to the top of the scoreboard
and if it's threesomes you like you're
going to love some of james bond's
iconic moments
the man who's given us by far the most
amount of legacy defining sequences
can't kick back just yet however this
round will favor
quality over quantity which doesn't
necessarily exclude 007 either from the
first time we see sean connery as bond
and dr
no all the way up through the very
memorable and unfortunate
man region torture poor daniel craig
endures in casino royale
every incarnation of britain's second
best spy justice for johnny english
provides us the audience with new
lasting memories
some of which are thanks to his
villainous counterparts goldfinger
expecting bond
to die crocodile hopscotch and live and
let die
and famke janssen's xenia onotop's legs
of death
all come to mind bond can equally
impress us with his fighting ability as
evidenced
by george lazenby kicking ass beachside
in on her majesty's
secret service and his tendency to go
rogue as when timothy dalton's 007
resigns just so he can truly get the
nefarious sanchez
once and for all we love a suave james
bond like when pierce brosnan adjusts
his tie before getting on with the
mission
but we also adore the rough and tumble
daniel craig iteration
doing his best to pass mi6's intense
physical in skyfall
and for all the street cred craig gets
as being a rowdy born style brawler
when he lands on top of the train at the
outset of skyfall
you're damn right the dude to justice
cufflinks
while we wait to see that james swann
song in no time to get a release date
we can now turn our attention to a man
who ironically
might have taught that old dog some new
tricks jason
bourne we're introduced to a very
soaking wet born but once he's back
on land we quickly see him gain his
fighting sea legs when confronted
like a great comedian handling a front
row heckler bourne takes down his foes
quick
hard and for good and a year before mark
wahlberg and the italian job funky bunch
helped minnie cooper stock soar it was
jason bourne who showed off the
maneuverability of that vehicle design
chase scenes became a hallmark of the
franchise and i'll give a big nod to the
bourne legacy motorcycle duel
as well as the epic vegas destruction at
the end of the fourth born flick
but still when i think of that movie i
fondly recalled the one punch knockout
and overall bourne's ultimate supreme
legacy identifies as mind-boggling
one-on-one battles with the asset
with jarda or here where he beats up a
guy with a magazine
yes a magazine you're not even safe from
jason in a dentist office waiting room
speaking of nice teeth tom cruise has
some good chompers and shockingly
they're still intact even after all the
cray-cray stunt work he's done over the
years
he did break multiple ribs i think in
that fallout jump but he still leaped
over the finish line
and yes he was actually on the side of
an in-flight airplane for rogue nation
but somehow i'm even more impressed with
the motorcycle chase for the ages
in that very same movie kids uncle mark
wants you to wear a helmet earlier films
in the franchise had tons of fun with
ethan hunt
hanging on by a literal thread and i
think we can all admit we would have
been caught red-handed had that been us
trying to steal a floppy disk from
langley
i'm sorry sir i really just needed that
10 free hours of america online
even though it's the lowest of the
franchise in terms of tomato meter
mission impossible 2 did open with a
stunning rock climbing sequence
and it closed with a knife almost going
through tom cruise's eye
not the character ethan hunt the actor
too the knife is really that close
if you have a queasy tummy do not watch
those behind the scenes
what's the more iconic series of moments
for you is your beauty beholden to a
vast array of fun gadgets and one-liners
or are you more of a down and dirty mono
amano fighter
or do you just love getting to see a
good stunt on the biggest screen
possible
i do love what all three spies bring to
the table in this round but no one goes
more
all out for their craft than tom cruise
and by proxy that makes ethan hunt the
purveyor
of the highest quality iconic moments
topped of course by my all-time favorite
the majestic ghost protocol building
dangling death defying exercise and
audience
sense stimulation i look at tom cruise
performing his own stunts like i do
thursday night football games
they are highly unnecessary and i fear
for the player's safety but am i gonna
watch every moment of it
you're damn right i will ethan hunt wins
round four and goes up by one
good i think he's got a little in a hand
look out and now it's time for the wild
card round
would you rather okay okay let's get
everyone's mind
out of the gutter right now it's not
that kind of would you rather
although an mfk scenario between these
three fictional gentlemen is probably a
fun game to play
at your leisure and while ethan hunt
seems to be the only one of our eligible
bachelors who even farts with the idea
of marriage
each super spy brings their own unique
methodology to the table
which begs the question that could
determine the match in this round
who would you rather be the writing's on
the wall
yep that's right you're saying goodbye
to your ordinary life forever
and becoming either a james bond or an
ethan hunt or a jason bourne
so for instance if you're currently say
a comedian who hosts a talk show where
you make art competitive for funsies
would you rather give that up for an
impossible mission a meticulously
crafted martini
or a supreme-born adventure let's take a
look at the best qualities of our
one job and the three very divergent
lifestyles therein to determine a victor
ethan hunt has a good time and that
seems to be the case
even when he's not out on a mission why
because he's got a girlfriend
and she seems pretty sweet on him or at
least she was at the outset of mission
impossible three
and then kind of sort of later in the
franchise but not really
she knows he'll never stop never
stopping until he's dead
and he's starting to accept that his
fate is that of a loner but why mope
around lamenting your lone wolf future
if that's gonna happen anyway bring some
fun friends along for the hand basket
ride into hell
ethan has cool pals that managed to fill
every need one could desire
they're great at hacking you in any
mainframe and if you don't already look
like stud tom cruise don't worry
there is a mask for that ethan hunt is
the perfect template for folks who want
to go on a joyous harebrained vacation
and while you're out there you might as
well save the day too jason bourne also
gets the day
saved but in a very different fashion
first of all
let's start with fashion he doesn't have
much when you have trouble remembering
your name
or how you got there in the first place
the acquisition of fine threads
doesn't necessarily make you dent in
your to-do list and whereas ethan
prefers the groupon discount you'll get
when traveling in a
group jason bourne prefers the rogue
life of going it solo
which is why i personally find his
lifestyle so appealing
you're rarely seen rarely heard and no
one bugs you about why you didn't wish
them a happy birthday
you're 41 brett get over it if you
become jason bourne gone are the days of
worrying about identity theft you've
already got loads of passports and
aliases to play with
and not even the world's finest student
loan collector can track you down to ask
how much you'd like your next monthly
installment to be
it's almost like paradise except you
never get to chill
like ever even when you have a sweet
little pad right on the ocean and you're
exercising every morning and romancing
your sweetheart
someone is always looking for you you're
not living in peaceful isolation
you're on the run jason bourne is like
the best survivor in the movie it
follows
you may all live your competition but
you're always on the go
and if you ever finally do get a chance
to rest good luck staying in rem with
all those flashback nightmares to brutal
weapon weapon-like ex-training that you
endured
now james bond that's a guy who enjoys a
good
nap i guess sleep is enhanced after you
have a few drinks and a mysterious
um bedfellow to accompany you in the
process
forget fighting styles and daredevil
stunts even globetrotting spies need a
good
cuddle every now and again bond has
endured for over six decades precisely
because his lifestyle
is the eternal dream you jet set party
romance save the world deliver the
perfect quip rinse
repeat after studying the entire double
07 library time and time again
i've never seen bond have to clock in
wear a hair net or send an invoice
sometimes his government agency pals can
be somewhat inept but that just seems to
stoke
his own competitive fire ideally i could
be the bond of connery
moore or even the brosnan era the daniel
craig one looks a little more daunting
the high wire fight scenes losing the
lady you thought was your one and only
the ever expanding industry of body
torture
but even he finds time to chill at the
bar and perfectly tailored clothes
chat it up with the locals do more than
a few talking with a few of the locals
in particular
and then employ find new gadgets and
drive away successfully
in a luxury sports car there is no
substitute for bond and that phrase is
especially true
when it comes to the overall lifestyle
born and hunt certainly have their
upside
but with double 07 there is no downside
thus it is jimmy bond that wins the
would you rather wild card round
and he ties ethan hunt with two points
apiece
bond james bond
oh no which means i mark have to pick
the one true winner here in my fun
little epilogue
if it's a super spy you want jason
bourne james bond
or ethan hunt will do the job just fine
but for the greatest of them all
i'm still taking the og goat the grand
pappy of them all
james bond if mission impossible movies
keep doing buffo business that decision
could change
and who knows if anyone will ever be
able to add to the bourne legacy
i just know the legacy of double 07 has
already been cemented for some time now
we just keep adding fun new bricks to
the sculpture james bond wins but that's
just my little novella
how about you let us know which
spectacularly sterling secret agent
you like the best and why you can hit me
up on social media
at mark ellis live or go to any of
rotten tomatoes social media channels
thanks for watching everyone i'm mark
ellis reminding you
we need another austin powers movie yeah
baby
yeah that wasn't even british
that's right
you